after weeks of searching new Clues
revealed on Wednesday have renewed hope
for the fate of four children missing in
the Colombian Amazon jungle anukak
indigenous woman found a pink baby
bottle cap the case of a smartphone and
most importantly a used diaper they are
the latest signs that the children
survived the crash on May 1st and set
off into the rainforest we found a
makeshift shelter for three people and
we found a used diaper a pair of blue
shoes which we can assume belongs to the
four-year-old boy and the path that gets
lost after a hundred meters to the
southwest of our search area so we know
that the four children were alive after
the crash of the aircraft
the plane that had taken off from a
remote Village crashed deep into the
jungle the body of the children's Mother
and another two adults were found last
week when soldiers managed to reach the
crash site after days of severe weather
since then the operation has continued
Around the Clock beneath the dance for
his canopy
the children are aged 13 9 4 and 11
months the relatives say they know the
jungle well
some 200 indigenous people have arrived
in recent days to assist the military
operations some performing rituals to
clear the way and find the children
the fate of the four children has become
a national issue president Gustavo Petro
Drew Global attention to the incident
tweeting the children had been found he
later deleted it saying the information
was not confirmed on Friday the military
released a map of the area of operation
covering a stretch of jungle of over 300
square kilometers and saying they will
continue searching until the children
are found from above Colombian aircraft
are using loudspeakers to play messages
from the kid's grandmother in their
native language and launching survival
kits and pamphlets into the jungle
but despite the new Clues with every
passing day the hope of finding the
children alive drops a little leaving an
entire country holding its bread and
praying for a breakthrough Alessandra Al
Jazeera Bogota
a brawl has broken out on